parrot a tenté pas bien sûr la caméra
maintenant je tourne je veux maintenant
mais attends c'est plutôt à moi de faire
parce qu'en fait on a été déréglé
on va désole un petit problème de caméra
au début et tout mais bon viendront
vient de vivre la défaite de maxime en
direct et bon ben voilà fin annoncée on
est comme après l'euro de football la
défaite contre le portugal femmes ouais
un peu à peu un sommet c'est comme ça
mais quoi enfin ça au site il faut
reconnaître qu'à rognant a fait un bon
match et est ok c'est pas le moment
d'aller critique et maxime j'ai pas
j'avais des posts sur facebook pas
forcément coup sérieux mais qui c'est
qui va laisser ses clubs retourner qui
pue le soutien aux quais les mecs de
nous tous ils finissent par perdre basse
et david et méritait pas ça une chance
va rapporter bat applaudi et étant dit
bonne chance
voilà alors je salue rempli le prochain
truc important comme maxime et on va
tout donner pour se qualifie la noire
d'où il partira magasin mais c'est
exactement ce dont parlait pendant le
live c'est à dire que les mecs voilà si
tu si tu tire sur la barre que la balle
fait poteau sortant tu es tu es un idiot
s'est elle fait pourtant trente et un
génie il fallait alors c'est pas comme
ça le sport non on va d analyse des
façons comme ça mais non ça ne
marcherait qu'elle voit son alléchant
qui soutient quoi où les équipes que je
soutiens la cour fédérale importe quoi
j'étais quand même pour lui d'atteindre
il a gagné je suis pas revenu pour lui
juste années j'étais super content et
dépendant que c'est pareil pour sainté
offrir la victoire à ses côtés d'un
supporter là je pense est normal
doug macray pas fait n'importe quoi la
famille la coupe du monde les a tous
deux dans le match par l'armée guesdon
toiles de raoul du tout à la fin bien là
mais c'est fantastique ce jour donné non
plus c'est fantastique
enfin vous pouvez pas rêver mieux mais
comme on a dit on ne pouvait pas rêver
mieux mais on voulait qu'ils gagnent à
la fin c'est pour ça que c'est parfait
une victoire donc c'est juste moi
parfait
c'est aussi pour ça qu'on aime le sport
c'est pour vivre des moments comme ça
[Musique]
mais bon qu'est ce que tu veux c'est la
vie c'est passé les agents qui sont
réglés dans le chat va petit à petit les
ca river alors sélectionné c'est qu'il
peut être lors à la wild card quand même
et je pense pas parce que problème c'est
que ces décès c'est un sponsor russe
donc bon garçon avait déjà il peut
encore qualifier sans avoir besoin de
votre garde parce que on aura le grand
prix le grand prix et il en course
alors s'il gagne cette étape à majorque
lent début novembre
l'art éventuellement pourra re suivre
quelques parties en direct vers la fin
si on sent qu'il peut se qualifier
oui pourquoi pas pourquoi pas du coup on
est un peu fatigués parce que votre
journée un peu maintenant on est fatigué
on aurait pu être fatigué au foriic
madoff savait fatigué coup de bambou
enfin voilà position finale bon ok mais
ok même brown vertex et cela est
évidemment le sort qui est jeu changer
les idées mais combien de temps vont se
remettre d'un truc comme ça à 4,5 jours
quand même pas dépendre de chacun va
peut-être vocaux fuste beaucoup moins
peut être que ça peut passer dessus non
à voguer moi je sais moi oui moi je
serai mais bon c'est dur après comme je
dis pas je vous le disais le truc c'est
que c'est pas pas comment bien c'est pas
une défaite terrain passe à côté tu t'en
veux quand t'es passé à côté
peux tu as raté je n'ai pas aimé la fait
son match et a remis en vie et voilà
donc tu peux pas t'en vouloir que
quelque part un jeu fermé à ce coup ci
vous avez
quand on a fait le maximum et ben c'est
bien arrêter sinon ça non mais ce qu'on
était euphorique
ouais après la première mais si tu
réfléchis sur le match aronian il a
peut-être un poil plus méritée sur ce
match là il a eu plus de bonnes
positions machin ça se joue à rien après
c'est comme laisser comme les finales de
ligue des champions ça peut jouer sur un
coup de pied arrêté ça joue sur un truc
mais sarre union qui a eu le plus
d'occasions après le truc c'est que
maxime a eu entre guillemets la balle de
match dans l'armageddon parce qu'ils
étaient mieux mais bon
mais après voilà bah tu joues ta peau
minutes avant ne faut pas tomber
machin est ok ok ça des piles ne pas
oublier que l'on joue on joue quand je
crois qu'on joue à une perte à granges
il ya le stress c'est tout ça c'est pas
la partie tu joues contre pour te
détendre quoi bon faudra qu'on fasse une
vidéo
fab sur sur le grand prix peut-être
juste en parlant de chiffres et ce qu'il
faut faire quoi peut-être on détaille un
peu tout ça parce que bon là on est
abattu mais d'un autre côté on n'est
quand même pas mal hein par rapport aux
grands prix je pense qu'avec grâce à la
qualification de dit qu'il irait nom
final on a peut-être juste besoin de
finir 2e ou 3e je sais pas quoi regarder
exactement et radjabov et tout ça et par
rapport à great choqué toute la
compagnie mais on n'est pas si mal en
fait
surtout si vraiment renverser avant la
règle et basta mais non c'est comme ça
entrée de la mort c'est le truc c'est la
patrie de trucs de tous les sportifs et
même quand tu gagnes tu sens pour
repartir de l'avant
patassé alors que non plus écrit cela
dit devoir se remettre au travail par ce
nouveau machin
ouais
non mais oui tu as raison tu as beaucoup
de philosophie dans tes paroles on sent
le coach de l'équipe de france
non non non en tout cas un grand bravo à
lui 1 nous en fait autant rêver de toute
façon dans tous les cas enfin merci
parce que s'il fait ainsi avait pas eu
maxime n'y aurait rien du tout faire là
il est éliminé donc il est déçu mais je
repars là s'il n'avait pas été là il y
aurait femmes y aurait rien à lui donc
enfin je préfère vivre ces émotions là
que deux parents vivent du tout d'abord
merci à lui mais forcément les gens qui
ont des messages de soutien sur son
twitter ou quoi vos applications vous
salut passait au dessus de la tête mais
ça me touchera forcément de se sentir
soutenu bas dans l'histoire évidemment
mais quand tu perds aussi est de voir
que c'est pas juste opportunistes les
bons commentaires c'est le soutien des
gens ouais ouais c'est sûr c'est sympa
les gens dont on peut on faire on dira
peut-être ça sur notre chaîne youtube du
coup comme il ya plus de gens qui
regardent l'on pourra dire qu'entre la
prochaine vidéo là sur la finale voilà
des messages de soutien maxim parce que
franchement il vous a fait rêver
je suis très très content ça les mecs
qui ont dit qu'ils ont mis des messages
négatifs sur facebook un très très
mécontents parce que je vois là c'est
enfin j'arrive donc aller jouer m'a dit
qu'elle fit or demi finale de coupe du
monde c'était si fort si tu es si fort
bon du coup nous on fait quoi on fait
des beats à quatre on fait n'importe
quoi chez toi tu habites sakate non
enfin je suis pas d'humeur à jouer aux
échecs là je sais pas j'ai peu de bien
bon je t'ajoute envie de 5,4 il est
juste une voiture connectée dont jeunes
actifs a second jaune je pense qu'il ya
de mieux à faire face comment ça va nous
changer les idées
allez on changeait vraiment ça me change
les idées en me tempère je n'aime pas ce
jeu à vinça tu te souviens
ouais je sais mais j'ai refait tu joues
mal mais en aimant bien fait
non mais peut-être que jouera de la
colline où un autre truc non non mais
d'être on n'a pas d'adversaire a
démontré beaucoup la norme
ça fait plaisir luczak 6 4
aussi beau que ça vous amuse en bas nous
là c'est difficile arrive on ne peut pas
se mettre de bonne humeur sur comment
non plus enfin géré par la diffusion
d'une souris mais bon là vu l'événement
enfin vu leur belle occasion celle pas
non plus un hoquet départementale peser
lui c'est comme si tu as ton équipe de
foot préférée dès qu'ils aient joué une
finale de coupe ou quoi tu perd aux tirs
au but a fait un gros match et ce qu'on
négocie pas combien de 15 jours c'est la
10e match de tennis c'est super chaud
score 5e set
chais pas 14-12 mama ok vous mais bon
les gens c'est un peu comme quelqu'un
qui a une licence à casillas et le suis
tellement triste pour maxime dont
quelques uns parlent de gens qui sont
dans le même temps le même état d'esprit
que nous ferons bien revient de prendre
même un coup de bombe en janvier de
maxime ça dépasse le cadre du
chauvinisme puis de maquettes français
on est forcément pour lui parce qu'il
est français on n'est finalement on est
enclin d'un autre patriote mais en plus
maximum et on aime bien le crois pas
c'est un mec sympa rend plus c'est
tellement sympa à brûler vue sur la
chaîne des vul est écoulé il n'a pas dit
je viens de filles et 1000 euros enfin
non il vient gratuit y j kelly donne de
son temps
moi ok m'a permis de faire club tournoi
gibraltar georges de voix paris avec les
bons - équipe de france et ont donc
c'est un plus c'est un très bon copain
quoi donc voilà ce que tu avais je suis
déçu c'est vraiment un mec bien mais
forcément à leur triste pour lui
et pas juste parce que c'est le français
qui perd pas bien le truc personnel
samedi soir bon mais à regarder un mec
bien aussi donc quelques bars mais enfin
bravo lui d'ailleurs près de toute façon
c'est même tu vois prête à renoncer
français maxime arménien vu nos
relations
je regardais des pommades sine qua non
coupable
c'est même pas une histoire de
patriotisme je ne sais quoi c'est c'est
juste boire rien je sais que ça mec bien
là
quand on se croise le saluent cependant
eu le temps de parler d'être un mec très
bien merci
c'est mieux qu'il ait rien contre un mec
très sympa contre lors des combats donc
voilà bravo bravo les hommes qui fait
une énorme année et puis là je lui
souhaite de gagner la coupe du monde
après bon là je profite pas quand même
veine le but c'était ventes d'arriva
soutien pour ce qu'elle fait pour les
candidats mais mais je souhaite aller au
fond voilà bravo à lui il faut qu'un mac
et non mais il mériterait de gagner les
candidats gérard briane pour sa carrière
ouais si l'apa vaccinons messi a pas
écrit tchouk alors là ça devient dur
pour lui alors on ne sait plus bas il ne
mérite peut-être jamais gagné en fait à
quoi éveiller à 3 deux jours après après
objectivement pour sa carrière la grippe
a c'est un mec qui doit jouer une scène
totalement d'avoir sa chance
c'est ce que j'adore live à saint-jeures
convoya talent talent et tout ça pour
être champion du monde il ya un truc il
ya une classe i réalité plus chaudes y a
pas chez tout le monde
évidemment on n'est pas chez tout le
monde mais quelques chez très très peu
de joueurs alors est ce que ton pseudo
ces familles qui font 20 membres
nombreux or je comprends tes family
surette chasse comme déconnecté ou pas
déjà je suis connecté jeu mon pseudo
qu'est-ce-qui raymond pseudo aurait dans
ce sens
je vous et en dressage zone matin
j'étais pas sur ce jeu d'échecs ait
dépassé coup de bambou dans le sens
quand tu connais tu commandes six heures
d'affilée cta le coup de bambou est à +
le feu rita puis nrj t'as plus rien tu
as l'impression n'est pas du côté laval
pour se reprendre ce soir mais ça c'est
moins grave non à ok on préfère faire un
bon là je serai dans cet état et maxime
se qualifier très bien enfin venu
plonger qui se qualifie de très loin on
est parti en fin ou la non pas en bullet
on va se mettre en moi j'ai rien
attention en train de faire n'importe
quoi ok on attend des joueurs là ok on
mettront pas non non c'est toi honte à
toi là on attendait jusqu'à - qu'est-ce
que je ne sais plus quoi ça la
proposition de jours ensemble à temps
j'accepte attends attends attends j'ai
annulé
c'est un truc alors que j'annule que je
veux j'ai accepté avec ce gars et
c'était dans le chat se j'annule et
c'était pas loin de chaptelat je parle
pour personne je vais aussi et je vois
pas comment elle va distribuer accepté
12 j'ai accepté
comment les parties on va attendre va
trouver des adversaires un tué quatre et
ont expliqué avec ce gars était là tu
peux traduit la partie désolé c'est la
dette le but serait de faire des parties
contre moi moi c'est parti on s'est
engagés les blancs c'est quoi la
résidence si je rate pas maintenant me
me refais le truc de nous appeler
l'échiquier quoi comme commencer l'année
il faut il faut que tu annules autres
partis ou abandonner j'arrive pas le
bouton c'est chiant mais le match qu al
hamedi je joue j'ai passé mes dix jeunes
appear quoi ou sa carte
j'ai toujours le beats a cassé pas les
vrais échecs à merde c'est pas du
plaisir ou suis en train de faire
n'importe quoi mais peut-être une pièce
qui arriverait ceku est arrêté jusqu'au
bout bon ben je me remets
maintenant ce jeu soit 4 pouces h 5 1 au
pire tu donnes une tour on s'en fout les
tours c'est de la merde on voit nommé
d'accord est-ce que c'est efficace
bon allez je balance une foule on s'en
fout fais gaffe il ya une tour qui va
arriver mais au moins je tu vois je
m'active ses actifs la notice
statistiques et pris un pion aussi
proche mouscron
je suis hyper actif là je suis en train
de m'activer de partout là où bon lui
aussi ça qui avec des moufles
interruption en russie stat est bien là
non voilà ça va pas visuellement je sais
aussi option c'est pas mal ce que j'ai
dit non le pion tu vas l'avoir sont en
bout le pion à temps ça gagne c'est un
pion voix basse à lui joué pour le sang
soit une pop plus consomment jusqu'à
ligne en défense grâce à un pion lui
aussi mais bon est une dame c'est une
dame samat à l'homme un pion cermak pour
toi ah oui il va jouer un couple ami tu
veut lui prendre son car il repose et un
cavalier je vais faire un olympia au
soleil roman moi ce sera votre jean plus
donc demain contribution trier hamas à
main sur est imprenable
la bouffe un pion 30 minutes et qui font
ça mais en fait ça a joué sur les deux
écrans g2 parce que je tu veux qu'on va
durer le jeu coquin du coup c'est bon
j'attends j'attends c'est fini on dit
non c'est bon
bon bah sa première victoire bon on et
repartir loisirs tel truc à moi je sais
pas je te mens maintenant j'écris un
mauvais truc mais en fait on pas ok je
suis remis sa carte je suis avec toi je
jouais alors attends vraiment mesquin
toc est joué ok on est reparti un rouge
contre mehdi a c'est moi qui joue contre
mehdi du voyage groupe solar solarc leur
falloir 218
ok on veut voir sur leurs fleurs quoi on
est pas mal là pour le moment si tu as
un pion là c'est bien bon c'est un guide
en vue pour le fion fait d'être de
retour
j'ai fermé mon jeu je tiens prends tout
ça qu'est ce que c'est que cette merde
tu vas tu te couches que d'apprendre
sont 44 est bon non mais je prends
l'avion je préfère bush va aux [ __ ] un
g5
mais quelque chose ils vont se faire
mater tous les astéroïdes vous déjà
protos 1 500 ils sont complètement
foutue là les mecs sur un fond de la mer
de la totale bonjour mon chemin
jusqu'aux la tête quand on est mieux
autant de partout
ben c'est pas mon adversaire joue pas le
tien non plus ne jouais pas tomber et
reviendra nous sommes toujours écouter
un échec s'il est inquiet et on foulera
le sol elles n'ont intéressé
mais en fait je m'en fous complètement
là dessous et quidonnent bubble fait la
chouette je vais le matin ou en tout cas
là je suis proche parce que je l'aimais
tension a baissé mon idée matin bon très
bien très bonne partie vidés on a gagné
en force la de partout bon bah écoute
pour le moment pour une fois se passe
bien bon ben c'est pas du crédit house
un ses urines saccades c'est un peu
différent
elle rejoue la française fasse tout
devrait se jouer des françaises est en
jeu sous la bruine jouer quatre bombes à
écouter tiens je te donne un cavalier
dans l'ouverture
il veut pas juste une touche rien à
[ __ ] moi il me joue une rue ils ont
fait quoi en faire un mail ouais avoir
dû s'expliquer moi ça te merde t'as un
pion pour moi non mais bon le truc ça ne
donne rien je vais dessiner ça c'est ça
et mac lactique casque moyens pour
traquer pièces qui arrivent c'est
d'extinction je bouge tous les trous au
fait nous faut pas qu'il donne moi ta
l'avant le talent premier regard il ne
faut rien changer cet adversaire en paix
est ce qu'on en fait tu vas récupérer
une tour la télé les plus attaquées et
des échecs mais je pense qu on vole aux
élites et je sors mes pièces je me
développe mes questions attention les
bo3 échec tu serais mal oui bon
voilà déjà une mouche ne vole autour du
match laval
la chasse à la mouche en fait tu vois je
suis pas focus sur l'échiquier baron la
tarte tatin avantage nadal conséquent qu
elle parce que je te renvoie encore un
fou et je te renvoie une dame à youtube
en deuil non non c'est en fait c'était
un pion un décor les deux trois coups et
puis après je vais m'arrêter moi je vais
attendre un peu je vais attendre un peu
pour pas qu'ils les caisses battue que
je suis moins six mois mais ça arrive à
récupérer afrique peut être materner
chèque on va attendre les acquis 12,4
ouais ça moi mais en fait s'il prend 1,6
tout juste un accord ait quand même
prendre le fou je sais pas mais bon pas
un échec s'en fout non mais bon enfin on
va jouer technique
je sens que mon roi d'angleterre en fait
dès qu'il vous focalisez 3 yamaha temps
déjà saluer qu'il a repris un pion
d'autres continuent à monter mon roi
quand je le trouve personne au club
le trot le club est dans la place vous
le troll club
alors il récupère quelques pièces car m
non
je crois que j'ai dit et de ce troll
dans l'aude rebaptise plus leur but est
de ne plus être impossible très mal bien
vite atteint damas de matadi je mange
j'ai six jeux tout manger apprécié de
finir on voir beauf tout on pose des
pièces blanches et les pistes n'arrache
à 15h et 16h vous à l'e3 les jeux contre
l'europe évolué comme prévu
on essaye de prendre tout le matériel
qui existe ouais ça s'est vu dans vos
pas mater on la retrouve on va direct du
jour c'est génial oh [ __ ] de film
n'est ni la faute
présentation votre hamas et je peux
faire ma tendre mais bon j'ai pas le
faire échec mais non mais moi je le
bouffer sent qu'ils sont bons chez paco
sortis indemnes a annoncé qu'ils vont
tomber avant mais au fond le vrai qu'on
avait fait pas mal de matos la haye où
ils sont plus forts c'était marrant les
derniers là je vous dresse platespin
masham installe une vingtaine d'avant tu
donnes pas de pattes de ne pas d'avion
pas qu'une bonne à rien bon le mec est
pas leur mot à dire ça son temps coule
toi je ne peux à grand chose
samba sy fait six ans déjà il songe à
pau mais j'en perds un peu je pense
non mais bon enfin le truc c'est le
choix que mike est pas là bah oui
j'étais ou de soja plus 23 ha oui mais
moi non mais bon rien donné quoi
mélodies dansantes a mérité toi tu as
joué donc moi je vais donner un cahier
sûrement très tôt voilà donc qui vaille
est donné par lui aussi ma ba non non il
regrette pas un pion il y beaucoup mieux
quand même faire attention pascaline
fait chialer de merde c'est un méchant
lui donner le foyer des gaz de l'air
qu'est ce que c'est bon je sais pas
combien ça fait un peu chier là son
ouverture
je comprends rien fait c'est l'avenir du
stream open je comprends rien à ce qui
fut [ __ ] je comprends rien
qu'est ce que c'est que cette merde
excusez moi cette merde inquiet mais je
te plonge ce lien la pure je suis
content je prends bon bah du coup on est
déjà bien c'est un cavalier un machin va
l'option la ville pourra espérer une
tour en fait mon soutien mais je sais
pas la position de la haine chez moi
c'est très compliqué je sais pas s'il
peut lui récupérer une tour ou un truc
ça m'aiderait il descend comme peut va
faire tour ah bah oui mais il va prendre
alors attend suivant ce qu'il fait je
peux avoir un math en un si jeune
non c'est bon on ne prend pas de rock
rock parfois je crois beaucoup
je couvre
faut qu'on repasse devant autant ce
serait nickel commerce je peux gagner
une dame une dame mais compte deux
cavaliers chez pas j'ai pas quel point
cette aide une dame
maintenant je peux plus de façons je
suis soucieux on joue tranquille on est
détendu tiens bon mange le pion vous me
regarde ce que je vais faire
il va venir prendre avec le roi et boum
tu t'écartes tu vois mes cavaliers
oui oui là ils sont inoffensifs quoi
c'est vous me suis dégagé avec tadam je
ne joue pas très bien senti juste un
montant qui bat en bout tu dégages
souffle comme les chats partout tout le
temps
il prend même pas mes pièces sequana
bana ok je dégage son cavalier ne sais
pas si simple la hourquie sais pas je
vais le dégager avec ces pièces là j'en
ai marre vous madame qui rentrent en jeu
où tu dégage de ce qui se fait sous bush
toulouse tient en échec là comme ce
faire récupérez une dame
bah je vais récupérer une dame ton toi
j'ai déjà une à poser en fait un sur moi
je vais faire une dame au prochain
ghaddab les lampes et des cerises sont
tous intéressés si tu suis ambitieux je
veux dire c'est leur choix
non mais je pense que je veux matin en
force
je pose un cavalier e set regardons à sa
contrée
35 le mari depuis bagdad façon dès mi
automne tu pourrais arrêter jouer
n'importe quand qu'est ce que c'est bien
il sort d'où ce chou c'est qui se fout
emballé ils sont finis là c'est fait
c'est bon ils peuvent plus rien faire là
c'est fini
j'ai presque envie le troll en lui
posant un pur en 17
leila double pack d'avants je suis
maintenant d'un thunder la marche est
revanche ou un jour économe dilatoire
prochain quand tu sais juste atteint
juste à ne pas jouer en fait de base
comment la pétanque quoi tu joues le
grand jeu tu joues pas juste je total
bull
les deux sens sur ce direct vaut plus
que d'habitude tu tiens le cochonnet
quoi ben merci salut à tous je sais pas
si on a des anglophones axe ou via enfin
l'ex de l'huisserie ne sais que c'est
pas souvent on peut un peu feignant le
mec très peu de live jamais allé je plus
des pions dégâts
qu'est ce que c'est que ça
à
bonjour je suis en train d' assez mal
jouer à jeu mèneront f1 comme dans la
grotte de mehdi quoi là le mec tantôt
fut excellent roi f1 j'ai jamais vu ça
merci c'est mehdi khouaja dégage il est
tenu que 13 ans et que tu apprends
déclassé jeu blanc de mes pièces autour
du roi mais dit quoi
mais ils voient qu'ils remontent la
gueule tu dégages ouais mais là tu
prends un pion mais c'est voilà je
reprends je t'emmerde
oui je te cloud ça m'encourage c'est
très intéressant aussi comme stratégie
alors on avait fait en fait s'il s'y
attendait par là il n'en peut plus un
genre de grands mâts verticaux à tout ça
l'amateur lambda il est mal quoi et même
un jeu aussi créative tiens je vais la
faune la créativité là j'en ai encore
plus loin je largue et une pièce pour
l'attack mais tu vas pour l' attaquent à
fond ces genres le cavagnan f5 laguiller
lo carrie diaries et je lui posais les
trucs de partout d'ailleurs il ne prend
même pas ma pièce il comprend il
comprend le traquenard se hissant que
vous ah s'il apprend finalement ils
réfléchissent et où je la prends mes
lacets traquenard c'est qu'il repose en
paix en fait je reprends sur échec
j'en peux plus quoi j'entends de créer
une muraille aux tombeaux enfin il ya
aucune chance m'attaque me bats encore
moins
il se prend la tête la muraille arrive
boula mur a changé c'est tout du coup la
muraille avance ces démarcheurs blanc où
ils sont armés
mais ces démarcheurs quand même pas
maintien blue prend une tour la démarche
car noir sans route
j'ai tout de suite eh bien tu je
récupère tout le matos à michael et il
va sacrifier un fou du coup pour il
tempéré se vendant les marches armoire
ça vaut bien foutu et bien entre eux
plus en face aussi
si on va des fous de partout en suisse
c'est génial maintenant je donne une
pièce en un couple j'ai juste oublié
quoi quelle horreur c'est le tournant du
match fade mais n'ont pas encore renvoyé
mais pions je suis chaud non mais aussi
je suis bon je veux recréer une muraille
suis très content on l'a en fait c'est
ouf
bâton rouge sur mon roi joue très bien
le truc est assez drôle c'est qu'en fait
je sacrifiais ce compte des pions tient
boum boum boum fab
tu as une dame qui arrive je paye samedi
les marcheurs je veux que des marcheurs
en fait que des marcheurs est tombé
suite repris le marcheur fait apte à une
dame qui va t'arriver dessus c'est un
squat où la dame une fois mr je fais
matériaux sains au nom quel idiot j'ai
oublié gommage j'ai oublié à tour c'est
une fantastique partie ce dommage
pas assez concentré fazila je vous ai
une belle partie le check in
[Musique]
mais dommage cette défaite met fin à
l'invincibilité ciboure ' je suis pas
vrai que j'ai une française sans jouer
c'est 5 h pour autant aux échecs ce
mauvais autant à ce truc bizarre ça et
de faire des trous et apprendre un tueur
en d6 influence et 7 et une avalanche
non mais c'est juste que j'ai du mal
avec la différence avec les vrais échecs
en fait ce faire il faut échec fait on
comprend un nom auront rejoint du lot je
vous comprends rien mon jour a dit me
suis pas je vais chercher sa tour
je passe les autres qui jouent en face
d'eux ils comprennent ce qu'ils font en
fait je pense personne ne comprend bs
des aspects à la scop d'aller voir est
étonnant
tu pourrais me choper sont fous ça fait
pas mal mais je suis pas sûr il joe
budden
je pense que je l'aimé laquelle mon fou
face de lui ce que je vais te prendre un
cavalier en fait mon job j'aurais même
pas très chic et brendan le qui viennent
moi j'ai des marcheurs
je prends malansac mais marc chamard
saddam verront pas les voir revenir chez
les bleus après ça devient marché à
bourg - fait beaucoup mieux dans le
monde touche te demande un peu comme les
dragues
c'est ça tous nos cheveux noirs ici
lâche rien qui plus que de dire je sais
plus je crois qu'il est je crois qu'il
va se faire mater comment donc jamais
m'arrêter comme jamais on me manque
qu'est ce que c'est que vos niveaux
d'échappement tas mais je suis prêt pour
ça
ce parc je n'arrive pas à mater
visiblement que mais je suis toujours
peur de me faire contre matt est en fait
à ce jeu c'est très attention lorsque je
poste je peux encore jouer trois coups
sans risque
là tu as maté la à nos attentes mais a
réussi jeudi l'annoncé c'est cool mais
ça reprend tout le temps qu en amont
pour souffler quoi on ne se fait jamais
en fait non je prendrais qu'avais-je
parvenant avec je profite pour inscrire
des messages textes de comme tous les
doubles vérifications
je commencerai ce qu'ils font en fait
j'en peux plus
moi je comprends rien à rien en fait je
m'en fous moi je me développe
l'échiquier en gros la vache et à me
développer tout bêtement je revois ton
le chic mais en fait je suis en fait
enfoncer un pion est c'est ça le truc
c'est que s'il prend un pion je suis mal
en fait je suis dans la vallée il faut
des trucs là il faut quoi bon alors je
suis mal il faudra ivoirien rudy guede
un flou je compte beaucoup
la merde c'est pas un chemin qu'avait eu
trop de manques et dont je me sers
attaqué ça tu me dire en fait six mois
en fait c'est pas kata si j'ai le temps
de râler mon ressentent merde j'ai parlé
de ce qu'il adopte un bon ça voilà je
vais me faire mateja le fou qui revient
en h4 monroy ce bar à jamais ces morts
on peut abandonner quand il est un pion
qui arrive là c'est mort ces données on
peut se tromper
pendant ce temps c'est moi qui aime car
ma ceinture pour te soutenir
on va voir ça sur c'est el hadji diouf
choquant
fait du bien merde je suis super content
mais bon là le truc c'est que him matin
ce que maintenant avec lui en cavalier
il me maths c'est fini ben tant pis on a
tous les deux super macho et surtout tu
vois quoi à 200% mois contre les pièces
sur mon style un peu plus que toi je
vais mais d'autres horizons donc très
recommandée pour le 2 à 4 attention pour
entreprendre des trous partout
boum voilà c'est moi qui fait gagner des
points si mon adversaire ne joue pas
c'est moi qui suis surtout les qui tira
les feux du marron j'ai envie de te dire
prends des marrous les marrons du feu
aussitôt les feux du marron fait j'en
peux plus fait c'est celle dont je
m'étonne ruse il ya pas de vue de sa 4e
en fait ouais c'est une méthode pratique
[Musique]
mais moi je demande à finir cette partie
clairement été achevés par par la
défaite de maxime complètement pls
car on a reçu un nouveau type de 10
euros après la fin du stream merci à
j'ai gagné sept points faibles abandon
lines est ce que tu as joué détient
toujours fait nous horizons et du coût
des séjours en face ouais
qu'attends tu t'attaches cinq à six
semble bien ça s'est arrêté de jouer
trois destins que ça va non s'il rejoue
les convois ce qui leur arrive je fais
g5 aussi je t'ai vu quoi je pouvais pas
en empêcher c'est trop dans l'esprit
ebooks mais j'ai joué à fond dans
l'esprit quoi j'ai mis la tour en g8
j'attends tapis qu'une donne un carrier
pour l'opposant h3 en fait un boubou
dégage est un peu plus la face est un
peu attention parce qu'il a pris du
matos mais c'est quand même rasé
j'étais quand même rasé compte deux
cavaliers dam tour pions mais ça ce
matin
qu'est ce que c'est que ça new york et
h3 p 10
je ne peux pas te dire tu es bon je m'en
fout quoi en fait me poser un peu
d'instruments des quatre champions tu
fais les marches à relent de la ville
veut faire que vaille h3 mais ce que ça
intéresse inscrits fo prend est-ce que
j'ai quelque chose à [ __ ] moi bon bah
tiens je me cassais comment il est très
très bien moi
attends qu est-ce que qu'est ce qui te
faudrait pour un cavalier toujours sympa
cavaillé et sucrés mais bon je pose un
petit plomb assistent histoire de poser
le socle qua non moi je suis enfin
l'essai du chopin cavale comme cela se
fait d'une pierre deux coups fumeux
départ l'arrivée 2 je repars à temps
plongé cet homme en tête ce n'est plus
en plus ma recherche en lançant plus en
plus proche du peuple en 2 vs zombies
souper record sous père quand on ne
comprend plus ici parce que je mets ce
criquet mettant le firent la longue
pause et cinq tours je suis une
amoureuse fuite mais en fait si je ne
joue plus il est mort en fait allé voir
se terminer
tu as perdu là faut qu'ils me prennent
un truc là enfin ça c'est leur seule
chance c'est de prendre le cas mais en
fait ce qui fait mais bon je reprends
mais tu me peu le mater ou quoi
tu donnes en la met sa main il peut
poser le cavalier en fait lui alors là
je te dis faut bien je te fais ça
dames tu vas son ps avec champions tu
n'as pas d'échec vraiment je ne joue pas
j'attends donc voilà je laisse le galère
vas-y sauf toi up
bon bah tu peux jouer revenir comme ça
sans que je ramène les marchés partout
déploré trois des six mois là c'est bon
il reste 45 sous quarante et une semaine
là c'est fini
et puis j'ai fait roi 8 dames j'ai vite
vous devez vous donne mes filles comme
ça matmat ses murs nasa report ou la
super mamie g kaboom la grob vous vous
fasse ça a bien marché je pense fait qu'
ils sont spécialisés dans ce jeu mais
quand tu es complètement fou a peut-être
c'est bien quoi attac spike away qui
crachent 523 votre matou fonds b deux
attaques spike c'est horrible on joue 5
n'est pas un bras de fer il fait pas le
droit de faire un top 7 en un cavalier
la manquez pas bon je le sorte un très
bon la joue vite donc il en pls l'autre
en face complètement conventionnel dans
ta gueule tu dégages
bon on est créatif quel que soit le jeu
vattenfall europe
[Rires]
ouais moi une phase iii pour attaquer
mon swing poser un pion barrages 5 et
dégagent prend le pas il prend le fou
qu'un tiens regarde égale agir sur ce
boom
bah oui mais qui n'en peuvent plus
pranger 4 ça ça n'a aucun intérêt ce que
ton contre je pose un pion qu'est ce que
c'est que si tu donnes pas de damas son
chef le temps d'un ou pas de tourner la
page donne pas de toi donc [ __ ]
heureusement autant non mais
heureusement du zinc a rallié parce que
sinon un vrai heureusement que j'ai ça
au pire tu es mis autant oui et non si
on peut garder si on peut augmenter
l'avancé autant c'est pas mal voilà là
de façon je suis bon mais où il a tenu
autant c'est hyper important mais j'ai
figé une dame juste à reculer une je
prends une pièce au passage vu imposer
un pion qui raddad
il va être en pls faut pas que les
hommes de la balustrade madame bachelot
je m'attendais donc je vais prendre une
fois mais qu'il faut ranger sans que la
regarde j'ai pas vu je dois faire j'ai
quatre doute fait drop
laissez vous flânerez joie que je vois
plus rien faire là je crois que j'ai mon
cerveau qui est out of service attacks
on se fasse une fois une une session
quand même quand on est plus ou moins en
forme nommée crête direct du fait d'une
robe il s'est senti obligé de vendre
affûté en sacrifiant une pièce direct -
6 h en pointe ou sélection de manière
grotesque
écoute maintenant on fait des quatre
volumes est un peu plus en face en cure
dix équipes
c'est génial la grandville sarsgaard des
personnes et j'avais pensé qui s'y
connaît des français quoi on passe aux
jeunes des pions ce raffut défoncer sur
un g 2 h de journée à damas en soutien
et mon prestige et défoncé est ce que je
fais des grands bossi quoi quand on est
tous les deux des fonds c'est en fait
mais mais c'est hyperbole donne un petit
conte attaque geste à très très
attention
là cet idiot il se verrait bien regarder
les fantastiques la position moi je
voyage partout on ne sait plus bah non
en fait je veux lui faire faut prendre
cinq à tout moment fait pas d'ailleurs
il prend ça et mes bons et que tu prends
mes mais bon faire des trucs c'est qui
voilà à des cages
il y en a marre qu alors attends me
paraissent plus là ce qui fait le mec là
il y en avait déjà donné une tour dont
kung fu long tu m'en fous complètement
du feeling tour et c'est tout tout ce
qu'il ya à savoir
en fait je pense qu'il ya sermat et la
lumière
tu sais que je peux chez n'avoue pas un
film impressionnant tout ce que tu veux
en fait le film madame je file madame je
comprends pas ton jeu réussit pas à ma
télé en fait d'avoir bâti est trop tôt
j'ai perdu contre attaques sinon là
normalement normalement il devait avoir
un match fort c'est juste que je n'ai
pas trouvé
du coup joulin mais ça va en fait je
crois que c'est en train de trouver là
[Musique]
là je suis en vain de trouver me contre
attaque de uche son nom en fait moi ces
matelas sur b4 ça dégage je veux accor
reprend ses cinq as je faisais un point
b 6 il repère leur deuil mais il n'y a
pas deux des quatre guides c'est très
bien bombardé grob du groupe de partout
moi ce n'est pas fantastique mais
partagent des pâtes fameuse bahamas et
une grave
forcément c'était bien alors au delà des
sur twitch il dit qu'il a battu jeudi
soir mais oui tous les jeudis soirs il
dit le retour de la bonne humeur d'exact
étions exactement ça qu'il a fait lui un
café très bonne idée ça détend dire dis
n'importe qui fait n'importe quoi deux
minutes plus tard ça amène les saccades
bonne idée puisque - c'est un autre jeu
quoi enfin je pense que c'est ça qu'on
n'aurait pas réussi à jouer là c'est
complètement stupide
ça nous caractérise quelque part de
stupidité dallas physique caractérise un
stream par nous caractérise en fait on
pourra faire pendant qu on au maroc et
choix des ddd très bonne idée ça stupide
que stupidité l'attention soutenue s'est
très vite ravens un injuste et à la
femme qui a fait rire est-ce que je
monte sur la caméra ce que ma femme a
cuisiné non invasive je vois pas là je
ne comprends pas nous votons repas bas
il est pas très beau là elle s'est déjà
coupé mais ça a l'air très très bon là
c'est quoi un rookie ouais bon c'est
monsieur bah je sais pas je dis au
hasard non mais si sa routine
j'ai le fluide quoi bon du coup a subi
des actes avec les gens ils sont plus de
120 lits par de plus en plus tard amené
le rôti gens se dit qu'on va je me casse
je ne veux pas voir ça et c'est reparti
même chaste et c'est parti achtung j 4
voilà aussi en fait j'attends à la fuite
à pied en scène plongé de 10,4 au 6e le
mako km/h 4 dégage
i'm a fait à trois là ici liste en île
sans flagrant bla il s'est prononcé pour
voir mon option quoi l'armistice amis
sont là mais oui je pars le rustique et
en valais où cette salle b4 partout
dégage c'est un fait unique une loi
quand tu perds ton cavaliers déjà y
meurt il meurt sur le champ de bataille
mais appliquée ou le four vient en effet
un couvre harry kalas voilà fantasti
globine y attend coup là il veut faire
un plan b 2-3 est ce que on peut
peut-être gagner un pion enfin il peut
sacrifier pourquoi un pion mais
s'attache aux mp3 une finale moi je m'en
fous je serai donc pas vas-y toi ce que
tu vois je te frère qui est d'un petit
par orange sport joue solide
là ils refusent l'échangé d'un bon bah
du coup je prends le centre vous
apprendre les allemands je prends 230
motos par des pièces qui est arrivé
dessus fort que le temps fasse bon usage
et que tu dises où je protège mon roi la
réutilisent la faute attaque parce que
j'attendais françois tu peux peut-être
prendre ce nom peut parfois je fais ce
que tu veux c'est quoi ce coup non en
fait si tu donnes rien je vais prendre
les 3 et je vais prendre là mais donne
pas de cavale d'un arrière
le fou fou c'est la seule pièce tu peux
donner
bon si je peux donner un sou est un sou
par des tentatives mais je sais pas si
c'était très mal pour toi non c'est pas
mal du tout pareil pose-t-on connaissent
pas oui ni non être un métier l'oricon
d'agrabah normal ça aux rixes et qu'il
n'est pas de cavale pour que mon bras
parce que là on voyait bien caché non
mais ils n'ont pas toujours assez grave
s'il un flou pas moins flou non vous
complètement ou moyen eu beaucoup de
bons jeux couvre et on contre attaque
tu appuies cas il appliqua sur son full
story pour lui dans un avion
ouais mais pas d'un voyage remarque
araignée là c'est pas trop grave que
l'espagnol moins grave qu'avant parce
que j'ai couvert les cases du cavalier
en fait quatre ans qu'il faisait un pion
ça nous fait peur eh ben je sacrifie je
le pose angers7
on est bien autant en suisse a très très
bien de partout tout ça est très très
mal autant d'hommes tu es content dame
fois ça me change pas grand chose
est-ce que moi si je lui donne une dame
c'est grave ou pas un peu ou pas
d'occasions
je crois que c'est pas si grave roger de
nom mais ok soir c'est qu'en fait je
vais supprimer son cavalier de merde
et puis et puis tant pis non mais je
suis bien je vais mettre ma tour un f5
mais c'est vrai que c'est qu'il peut
récupérer car elle chez toi ça fait
chier
bah tu t'en vas mais tu n'es pas bon tu
n'es pas là mais a vu qu'à seulement 1,7
pour qu'on ait bien autant qu'on y vient
de partout au petit gars détroit qu'est
ce que c'est que ça c'est un ami ça j'ai
attrapé beaucoup de questions et ces
matches maintenant à temps nana na na
nana na na na
et on perd des gens là je chantais mois
200 l'agencé barre de même le connaît il
chante mais tu n'es pas là sur le tchat
ils sont tous partis à l'est mais ouais
on les aimait bien mais là c'est trop
osé 3 on sait trop ce tropicaux au co
attaque spike alors là il comprend plus
ce que je fais moi je suis là ils
pensent que les prix ont doublé
il comprend pas en fait non mais bon là
les pions maintenant ils sont doublés je
pose un plan b 7 tu vois c'est très
intéressant à il est dans l'esprit à
fond la grèce a déjà même un peu trop
dans l'esprit je te vois pas on te voit
plus loin
c'est un peu chiant aussi un jeu j'aime
pas quand ça va pas réussir à récupérer
un cavaleur un truc du type ce sera
peut-être un bon pas tout de suite
un jour peut-être bas photo ap à mater
quoi que je vais prendre vis et je sais
que ça bouge en pièces numérique veut me
faire deux échecs de suite il avait un
faux pas des dames son chum être foutu
le sache ni tour papa de pièces de cette
race à tout peser chaque la terreur je
peux défendre comme ça mais c'est pareil
tous été récupérés le faut parce qu'en
fait connaître le fou en baisse est de
juger m dames ou non ma page position
mais ne donne rien en fait à temps et
que laisse moi je de trois coups pour
sortir ce qu il n 48 33
on est mal mais ça va nous présenter
plus rapide vers comptera dix secondes
on pourra jouer toute façon je te
rejoins coup là quand même pas trop
chiant suppose un pion f de faim pendant
deux ou trois coups que tu n'as rien
c'est même s'ils prônent un pion c'est
hyper rue jarry pose un pur et kz2 jared
and pranger trois étrangers un pince au
juste
ok je fais un truc en f2 et on respire
pas super kg d'échec faire ce que tu es
loin des cages
il ya un peu de temps parce qu'il est
mieux au temps mais on repasse devant on
vient vous aidant de retourner la
pression pour qu'ils jouent avec tata
directeur de l'abattoir il joue pas
alors ils veulent jouer moi je vous fais
ok tu peux attendre une image et sa
connerie
il me repose un pur f2i la hiérarchie
change faut juste que je mette un truc
un peu après je m'en fous je suis très
content blessé à temps permettez de
genre de 10 secondes d'avancé au départ
qui joue il va faire un peu de merde
c'est bon à prendre
je te prie mon863 temps mais nos joueurs
toujours en parce qu'en fait non
horaires ci prend le ballon qui rate
wimille immat puisque survie on prend un
tour d un match si on dame prend une âme
eu de match mais maintenant on l'unostra
contre attaque quoi dégage tu parle
d'art déjà fantastique hyper la haye
canada n'a jamais enfermer hop et le
plus d'hommes déjà la dame âgée il faut
quelque chose pour mater ou enfin la
dame que j'ai quoi il a ajouté qu'un fou
aux cavaliers demain j'aurai pu mater au
coude avant juste pas vu
dans le maiden tour il a plus de temps à
bondues il a essayé de terrain sa relaxe
est resté pas cette partie on a bien
géré les 70 soit de moins en moins c'est
génial du beurre de là bas tu me dis
justement bien au delà de la vraie
musique c'est génial que les gens parce
qu on était 200 et puis la fraude la vie
en couple alors comprendre la ps2
journée entre 13h 19h le live en plus
loin une misère on perd c'est la vie
mais bon vin prêt à gagner
bon on trouve on se dit bon monsieur
qu'on fasse ça fait des chèques ont des
prix mais bon comment on fait quand on
chante on dit n'importe quoi on crie
quoi mère nora tôt un peu non soyez
malheureux coire
de quel droit tu es heureux 2 3 calé à
bayonne qui est en train de perdre 10 0
contre grenoble
celle du rugby quel point pro d2 non
mais c'est dur d'être joyeux après les
événements à fort sur les échiquiers un
la journée bon personne décide à verizon
mort de son père et sur les robes ne
fait pas attendre l'adversaire je suis
parce qu'on pense qui se passe oui les
jo de bail qu'on n'en peut plus de magie
un train 8h du mat
c'est la pièce mais tu fais train lâche
le train train pour pauvres pour
toulouse me passager noir auquel j 5 ans
m mais c'est mal dans le train en fait
moi j'aime bien plus fatigué le train je
le sens que je sors de trois heures et
puis après j'ai le temps de faire des
trucs fin j'ai bien voyager entre est en
fait personne
bon voyage en train je ne sais
absolument rien en fait j'ai une vidéo
là pour nous remettre de bonne humeur
sur la chaîne d'ailleurs ces algues ou
pendant pendant le train mais je pense
face il analysé tavant importe valises
non mais quel chef watson et les
menteurs ça va être pas mal
bah je sais pas je connais pas la partie
mais en fait la sacrifie dame touré en
fait sur un match de l'escalier à la fin
mes joueurs ils sacrifient tout en fait
et à la fin elle est bien que parmi la
gent ailée windham un fou une tour et où
il peut rien empêcher en fait tu donnes
pas d'âme pas de mec me sacrifie tout
pour rien mais bon et s il n dams et les
trucks voiture juste eu de mots rien en
fait un pur déjà c'est quelque chose à
merde ils peuvent échanger les dames en
force
je perds pas pas à temps vois tu je ne
faut pas de dame du chum à toi ajuste la
gare des deux piasses a aucune raison
qu'ils donnent deux piasses c'est de la
merde ce qu'il fait mais il faut bien
donner quelques coups il faut au
contraire un rock à une façon à la
limite j'ai plus de temps que prévu
tec est de solidifier gagné 2,6 à fuji
stade et le japon mais bon il faut il
faut trois coups mais là on est bon là
il est en train de perdre trop de temps
il donne une table et coach me donne
tout mais bon donc choisi toi je leur
arrive il peut faire cailler gâté chaque
rue et puis il regagne dames chez moi
mais que ce parent d'élève ça tu vas
t'en fait autant mais s'arrêtera pas
beaucoup d'alliances
il va devoir jouer je vais couvrir à vii
mais ça je joue façon il faut bien
je vais couvrir
j'en ai marre qu ils me posent des pions
quoi je ne veux pas voir ce à quoi je ne
veux pas voir ses pions dans mon roi
mais afin que j'ai fait richesse
j'arrive ça attaque et numériques sur et
j'arrive pas à mettre des pièces non
mais ne fait rien en notre nom
on aimait me rate pions mais bon je les
blogs sur casse noix un truc c'est très
menaçant qu'il veut prendre un mec a
régné en fait alors qu'elle ne veut pas
à temps ne joue pas de la pâte sfk.un
secondes d'avancé alors que je couvre sa
encore mais devant l'algérie couvert jeu
le matra de couvercles des dual tu vas
faire x 3 l et le maté en force chez
paul dont je bouge des pièces à la fois
trois îles mater en force on a déjà
notre accueil avant la case éprise du
porge aux deux chefs
je suis passé bien j'ai plein de pièces
mais j'arrive je peux pas attaquer quoi
j'arrive il faut que tu ailles le matin
en force l'attentât jvg région et j'ai
pas de pièces en fait apposer le moment
ces rouleaux de ces jeunes dames ou un
truc comme ça il est mal quoi d'amis les
maths tour aussi c'est quoi une partie
des outils qui opposait intrus métiers
d'art à bas une bonne c'est matthew tour
c'est matt derrière une seconde il ne
menacerait en fait d'abord je vous à m
ça pourrait arriver quoi mais beaucoup
de ceux qui peut attendre un tout petit
peu je suis plus rapide que de façon non
mais attends c'est juste que je suis
rapide que lui là ils attendent mais
j'arrive on va pour atteindre et en
janvier de moscou des fonds peut scanner
peut me prendre une pièce sais pas non
non on échange surtout pas les dames
attend maintenant là on a une grosse
différence autant par ailleurs on a 30
secondes de plus le truc c'est pourquoi
pas que tu vas pas la pierre je veux
faire tu peux mettre au fond en b2 mais
non on échange jours est un peu comme ça
tu pourras m est obligé de faire des 6
et puis je vais commencer à y opposer
des pièces de partout je pouvoir
attaquer recteur bagdad ou swing pitt
est belge et du tps jules coiffage me
tuer moi il veut plein de points se
bouffent des examens de changer l'âme et
j'attends
on attend de voir ce que tu fais dans la
gagne en force avec le prêt move dame
prend b2 mais là on l'a eu en fin de
prêt vous des notes des banques
j'entends oui à sare jouent déjà temps
justin qu on est repassé à 126,55 10h10
250 $ bug faisant les choses qu'elle
juste un bug en fait sur le compteur de
jeu de tout vêtement en fait ouais je
suis un chat ma femme rien tu es trop
souvent le chat mais ce que je suis un
chat tu fais une robe mais c'est bien le
change en rien votre joueur d'échecs
échanges entend du bruit
ah ben voilà c'est parti
mais bon sait rien ou peu denses bon bah
non mais tu es bon tu t'inquiètes au
pire tu peux arrêter de jouer un jeu de
tous les côtés quoi
nombre de vlad
il veut nous aider il veut partir la
chaîne mais là pas de carte bleue combat
fut difficile de faire des dons dans ces
cas là puisque difficile avec le tipi
mais bon c'est pas grave
déjà tu fais des like déjà été l'ombre
de vlad et tous ses biens agents bon jeu
fluide et la donne pour moi je pouvais
changer d'armé n'imagine pas un cavalier
way et bouffon qui évolue
mais je peux te récupérer une dalle je
te récupérer deux sous la dent mais bon
si tu veux une dame âgée que de
s'adonner pas fait ce que tu veux comme
c'est à jamais de refus un truc c'est
que je pense que tu va mater tu vas tu
veux mettre plein d'échec dans la vue
freeks comme c'est quoi qu'il ya une
initiative dans la dame davantage tu as
besoin de quoi là pour le finir je suis
pas nous on aura peut être besoin de
rien envie de toi comme vous avez besoin
de personne
voilà oui besoin de rien envie de toi
allez tous me 4 f50 le trolleybus à 4 je
rêve c'est jeter des vies et on pille on
a extrait que ça ne sert à rien c'est
très mauvais j'espère vous besoin de
rien envie de toi là c'était fantastique
est arrivé comme ça la fleur au fusil
quoi fabien vous le fourbe et 7 il faut
échec ce que je prends juste un pion ce
point pas de reçu c'est vraiment
excitant où on reconstruit une maison et
s'est fait balancer un fou comme ça sur
la reconstruction et la construction la
reconstruction par le contient dix cas
des troupes est sacrifiée cas là je
pense pas qu'on va faire un cahier fils
intermédiaire vous lassez artistique
famille ça le temps c'est du beau jeu ni
besoin ni envie de donner madame baba
tout cas je vais bouffer la sienne bon
j'ai pu l'imposer
dommage ou d'un ce que j'ai dit bon bah
je me casse
allez je vous dans l'esprit à fond non
mais n'importe quoi sauf une dame bien
mieux plaisir ouais mais jouer dans
l'esprit à fond excuses ouais bah oui je
serai président wade de faire perpètrent
ou alors je donne une dame sans fil vers
fait passer par des moments là il faut
qu on fait de la merde la protection de
la mer liquide
je pars être pas beaucoup joué au but à
4 banon mais bon ça on a fait un truc
plus intéressant c'est quoi la question
ne veux pas manquer de respect mais dit
vous avez rarement jouées bisaga dans
votre vie on apprend maintenant peso
donc fait n'importe quoi et va lui
prendre son cavalier seul encore madame
je m'en fout en fait bon bah écoute on
va défendre mais comment je fais pour le
temps mais il a du matériel mais je m'en
fous de son matériel bon moi je veux
voir tomber 20 ans on sait très bien
compris et stratégiques bator devant la
grotte je sais que c'est à l'ouverture
phare du bout de sa 4e fait des trous je
ne sais pas comment je n'arrive pas à le
finir régiment de matériel ou la bombe
on va te donner le ch ou non on défend
les positions merde il a beaucoup de
pièces le pana a tient le feeling dame
ouais même la finance j'ai mis 9 jeux
fait le rose autour de moi
bah c'est pas trop donné c'est quand il
ya des trous vers mon temps mais je joue
vite on se donne pas grand chose ou s'il
avoue secondes mon adversaire par
quelques parties
mais bon le problème c'est que il a
toutes les pièces son adversaire va lui
aussi faire exercer comme sur ton
déchets qui en fait mais il est en
seconde ne veut pas retomber d'un joli
elle me fait perdre quatre ans puis est
tombé génial
ça joue déjà la haye hk où ben cheffaj
s'incarne dans les faits c'est bon je
parie boom son petit bout et finalement
solide
tu peux me balancer un pion en fout de
ce vote potter basse à peu près pareil
donc 1 728 appareils la même chose parce
qu'en fait je vais prendre un pareil
caissargues département de marmande
illégale a de partout sur les plages on
est près à l'attaquant sait qu'un voyais
pas mal de matos et je pense
qu'atteindre ici c'est que ça j'ai pas
je te pose est un pion l'apu une tour
qui arrive de nulle part on ne sait pas
pourquoi
comme zorro cantate pessisme non mariés
bien qu'issue tunisien
c'est des amis ça
boost acta d'anne k bon voilà ça va je
récupère un peu de matos enclenchement
ce pas un cavalier qui traîne pour tout
le monde on verra
et changer les pièces ça se fait plaisir
ou pas te voir il me faire bouffer des
trucs que tu veux jouer la même
pathologie qui je les pactes et demain
donc je vais changer d'âme je fais un
contre la montre individuel tokyo ne
trompe pas tous nos jours tout seul
ce n'est pas toi alévêque tente de
prendre des relais dont je suis l'autre
bon je fais ce que je peux ainsi ma
femme joue aux échecs non pas du tout on
ne joue pas seulement tu as passé ta pas
eu cette chance et par le surf avec les
cerfs-volants fait les cerfs-volants
teint du surf 6257 les échecs avec le
cerf-volant du coup pas de fous potsdam
potier valide pas tenir un bar tabac de
cavaliers pas surtout pas de rival ayant
fait pas de calais j'ai changé d'avis du
petit c'est plus simple
pédalier et puis on peut être un jour ça
changera voilà le truc c'est qu'on ait
mis autant vous les traîtres du combat
il me donne une dame pour prendre un
pion j'ai pas compris on y croit que ces
matches où ils oppriment à thouars
bon pas de cavalier en général toujours
la même histoire je peut claquer une
dame pour un peu souffler tu sais pas
faire je vais réfléchir à ce que je peux
jouer dans cette position mais je me
cassais courage de faire [ __ ] au 1,5
puis on prend quel point le troisième
vingt et c'est maintenant je suis bon
écoute je m'en fous je fais sont chères
pas besoin de souffler mais bon cavalier
pareille structure pas dans ma passion
qui rêvent 5 ça me saoule
je pense à poser des pièces pour lui
mettre des échecs
c'est donc mais on ne fait pas de mater
pour ma maman on va finir en jouant vite
on aura toujours
voilà il avait 17 secondes mon
adversaire quelque part ils peuvent donc
avec deux parcours juste moi qui sont en
train d échec oui c'est pour ça je vais
me donner une dame mais c'est pour faire
plus d'échecs en deux secondes il est
tombé attaque est tombé tomber tomber
tomber trouvé trouvé et rim rite aid one
to one fait des vrais blitz ont fait des
grog un peu de 804 c'est sympa ça change
mais je suis une attaque spike valgorge
ou contre notre ville craignant un bon
bain choisi de leur jauge et 4g simple
ils n'habitaient pas comprendre en fait
de ce qu'est cette boule taurine mais en
fait de la grave c'est très efficace ce
que l'image du jour les mêmes trucs
qu'on comprend est ce qu'ils font est là
du coup c'est vrai qu'ils comprennent
rien fait non plus le rythme est bon
mais deux relais 4 nages suis en train
de faire le fou qu'on fait
très solides je dégage jeunes cavaliers
celui du film absolument europe aivam sa
copine et [ __ ] donc que ça affirment
ces cris vers ton roi en fait non mais
je calme coiffe à développer vos pièces
le vous dépassez chez orange à 6 d'alain
cavalier on est peut-être content je
peux claqué la ba ba oui vasily
complètement vous plaisir base de
plusieurs moyens bravo kg pas besoin en
fait qu'aucune et relance donne pas de
cavalier peut-être il veut mettre un
truc en d6 pas la fin du monde c'est
juste pas viable ça se peut qu'avec un
carrier il soit matin a bondi l'an
prochain si sur l'allier en grosse ligne
de mire enfin il ya un fouille
accueillis sont pas soit non à la charia
ces matelas lacaille cemac c'est fini ok
j'ai envie de dire ça a été pareil cette
partie avec le plus en vue cette non
matteoli je trouve je trouve dans le
match et sympa non travers d'être super
impressionné
je suis très heureux de cette partie
enfantastiques replay du match de maxime
les peler de 6h fab j'ai passé les gens
qui ont regardé jusqu'au bout elle a
twitté il se fait un petit festin restos
et il dit de chaleureuses kong afin de
choses
féliciations à l'eva rognan c'est à dire
à très intense et j'ai même jour je suis
sûr que je te verra berlin avec man
comme je compte me remettre rapidement
il myspace à jour complète je limite
witch j'ai déjà dit pierse a posé pour
toi c'est quoi du matos et humour tout
va bien on part à la hausse en europe 1
je vais te maul
ça c'est cool ça choplin cavale papin
mon papa vient d'annoncer mon papillon
pas d'âme pas tout à fait tout ce qu'il
ya à savoir passion maintenant vraiment
quelques coups ça va pas durer longtemps
mais jusqu'aux normand chômage menace
maintenant de là ouais mais bon je suis
aussi plus âgés la première rangée très
célèbre sa marge et paillage et de
faibles et tout est fait en fait dans
quelques coups ça valait alors que ses
pièces il n'a rien fait c'est simple que
ça quand on est en train de plonger de
12,2 me prendre soin qu'il va partir et
puis sinon le projet sage des pions en
date c'est plusieurs gens que j'ai vite
g24 attend agissait de calculer il pâtit
valait donc une moc et trois sénateurs
en fait ça crie diom c'est que là on
fait avec ce qu'on en fait on a perdu
par m ce qui l'a empêché mon mater que
et qu'en fait je peux prendre mon
cavalier mais le truc c'est qu'on n'est
pas si mal autant mesdames émane de ce
match tu madame mcclure matca valait
alors à doké on a juste perdu de ce gp
la portée de 30 d'accor
non mais c'est pas fini je peux poser f2
je peux poser deux je faisais avec de
l'étoile aura le temps de faire d'un
cran et 5 très mou je vais poser un truc
quand au 2ième et merde il va prendre
avec le pion bah oui faut vraiment
attendre une seconde et du crime ou à
fond et ça ben arfa ça ok mais c'est
celle chance je suis pas quoi après
mauvais de puma
le cavalier seul même s'il a maintenant
deux coups vaut mieux que tu y es tu
les gars et si après vous être même si
on prend les gâteaux dame prend avec
lesquels preuves dont m c'est seulement
quoi bon je me dis qu'elle est j'ai
trois échecs c'est encore plus mal ah
oui c'est sans réservation se faire
qualifier trois échecs j'ai peur car il
y avait deux échecs comme ça a dû fermer
attendre avant d'avoir oui je sais mais
je vais attendre à rien du tout en fait
c'est excitant non ça va ainsi de la
saison 10 crime mais je marque lg 3 km2
francoeur en pls c'était génial
sans frais par une image
c'est fantastique pas du tout attendu je
pense à lui en baisse de niveau 50 ça je
pense à lui en baisse de niveau 2 150 3
qui n'en pouvaient plus là quand ils ont
vu ça c'était trop c'était trop quoi kg
3 ma tête j'en peux plus dense écran
mayra ipsa son iris ailleret 6032 stream
femmes chance mais on peut discuter et
prendre deux trois questions sur les
voies désolé ne pas avoir été en super
forme comme d'habitude mais bon c'était
difficile on a rigolé mais c'était
marrant finalement on ferait une vidéo
pour la chaîne bitstream comme ça de
grob grave envie de 5,4 ce sera marrant
ça me fera une petite vidéo sympa le
résultat est étonnant
rezaï est détonnant grob ruiz et toute
la bonne compagnie toutes les vraies
ouverture des échecs testé en deçà 4
tutti quanti
bondues qu'aujourd'hui c'était cool on
est quoi 1200 personnes dans le line bat
des records en a émis 500 mille cinq
cent mille 500 c'est quelque chose qu'on
aurait terrain dimanche aurait pu faire
il a été énorme et on s'est pas mal déjà
basses crise
c'est très bien on est très content bah
merci aux gens qui nous ont aidés à
travers des laïcs ne partagent les
commentaires les encouragements et
évidemment belle équipe il a aujourd'hui
bien reçu les gens ont été très généreux
donc je sais pas ce qu'ils sont là ici
ou quoi mais peu importe
merci voilà et et bombay nouvelle on va
se remettre
on va se remettre et ok on va tenter le
rêve d'aller gagner ce tournoi ce grand
prix des lots candidats et de revenir
plus fort que ce qu'on peut faire
faut qu'il gagne
qu'ils fassent dans les premières places
du grand prix et c'est tout enfin c'est
tout ce qui nous reste à faire c'est
tout
à
voilà questions et qu'on dise le plus
bas à pas grand chose
soirée tout seul on enferme comme ça le
stream
ouais deux parties ont fait tomber des
adversaires pour la sportivité et par
les zurichois mais voilà quoi on va
merci tout le monde d'avoir suivi encore
une fois et à bientôt les tontons ouais
voilà